Facebook's had a huge spotlight on them
lately as a result of this Cambridge
analytic a scandal where tens of
millions of profiles had been the data
from those profiles was inappropriately
used for political targeting by Trump's
data mining firm Cambridge analytic ah
and there have been calls for Facebook
founder Mark Zuckerberg to testify
before Congress it increasingly seems
like he's going to testify before
Congress but it's getting even worse for
Facebook and I actually am unsure that
it really should be and I'll explain
Mark Zuckerberg has announced that most
Facebook users should assume that their
public information has been scraped by
third parties now the headline sounds
shocking right wait wait a second the
data of most Facebook users has been
scraped wait a second what does that
even mean so it's terrible for Facebook
PR but it's not hugely surprising this
came up because during a call with
reporters yesterday Zuckerberg
specifically said I would assume if you
had that setting turned on that someone
at some point has access to your public
information in some way so what's going
on here is the following you can control
the privacy settings on your Facebook
profile and there is an optional
function that you can turn on or off
which allows people to search for you by
either typing in your phone number in a
Facebook search or typing in your email
address in a Facebook search people
wanted to gather profile information on
users that have that search feature to
connect it with data that they had
collected in some other way so you might
buy an email database and then you say I
want to learn more about these people
whose emails I bought so you search for
the emails in Facebook stay on Facebook
and depending on your profile settings
your profile would come up and whatever
information on your profile you make
public that person could then pull more
data out of your profile and link it
with your email address or with your
phone number and you might do that in
order to be able to offer people
products you might do it in order to
offer people services you might use that
information to call people and maybe
socially engineer a scam there are sort
of relatively benign and also very
malicious things you could do once you
scrape that data so
that's the news right and to many people
it's not even remotely surprising and I
hate to break it to you this is not a
defense of Facebook but if you're a
concern about that public data Google
has way way more on you than the third
parties that bought or scraped public
data off of Facebook data scraping isn't
illegal
it's the harvesting of information that
you've chosen to make public on your
facebook profile now it might be against
Facebook Terms of Service but it's not
illegal you might argue and you wouldn't
be wrong and arguing that maybe Facebook
doesn't make it super easy to actually
know what pieces of information are
available to the public or whether you
have that search function turn on but
obviously third parties are going to
scrape that information if they can
whether it concerns you is also for you
to decide but that's just the truth the
hope is that other companies are
managing and protecting the data better
than we now know Facebook has when it
comes to the data breach but this is
public data and I want to remind you
remember Equifax you might have already
forgotten about Equifax but what
happened with Equifax was endlessly
worse than what's going on with Facebook
sort of by definition because what
happened with Equifax includes financial
data potentially Social Security numbers
loans you hold credit information the
information that was scraped from
Facebook is data that you willingly put
there and made public either through
complex privacy settings or simply due
to indifference now that the counter to
that is Facebook's got two billion users
and Equifax has you know the data of 300
million people or something along those
lines needless to say the harm that
could be done to you with the Equifax
data breach is endlessly bigger and more
significant than what could happen with
Facebook except we've already mostly
forgotten about it and moved on and it's
unclear how serious the consequences are
even going to be for Equifax so not a
defense of Facebook but this should not
come as a surprise to anybody the video
you just watched was made possible by
support from you please go to
patreon.com/scishow
Pakman show you can make a pledge of as
little as $1 per month and every dollar
helps to support the work that we're
doing particularly in light of the
YouTube ad boycott which has been really
bad